yes open solo I only heard one first
women to ten wait to ten then it always
wish me in room 211
no way we're in the wrong word can
author you can't read anymore what God
there is no food in your house just
order something hey you hear like the TP
don't know I know this level's poet you
and I know can you turn it down trigger
system tray I love this speaker system
hey what's her Wi-Fi code get out
so is it okay no come on what up
I don't please just keep your time same
has been mine your home
what hey I'm going to study in little
scroll Scroll scroll here hey guys me
Amanda Cerny thank you so much for
watching my attorneys gifts and liking
and commenting
I literally read every single one of
them so thank you guys teen journey is
growing and I love it and want to
involve you guys even more so what I'm
doing now is I'm taking journeys get
suggestion ideas that means you just
comment below any good ideas that you
have for me and if I decide to choose
your idea that will shout you out in my
next journey skate youtube video so keep
the comments coming and who knows it
could be you love you guys and I'll see
you next week thistles